what will be the biggest stories of the
year ahead in 2019 surgeons get a new
view of the body
Japan welcomes the world Japan will be
undergoing a huge change the European
project falters my sense is that the
Euroskeptic cause in Europe will
continue to rise and fifty years after
Neil Armstrong made his giant leap new
nations shoot for the moon
[Music]
[Music]
20:19 will bring a whole new reality for
some patients going under the knife a
surgeons use augmented reality headsets
to help carry out operations the image
that you see is quite incredible we're
getting very quiet the first time I saw
it and I was very excited by their
capabilities doctors at st. Mary's
Hospital in London are pioneering the
use of AR to improve skin graft surgery
we're trying to see if or when T reality
can help identify the blood vessels that
supply the piece of skin that's required
as part of the reconstructive tissue
it's hoped this technology will make
surgery faster and safer for patients
multiple images from CT scans are
combined to make a 3d hologram which is
superimposed onto the surgeons real
world view we're hoping with this method
that you would get a much more accurate
and quicker understanding of anatomy a
piece of augmented reality gives so much
more information I could ever put in my
reports the AR headsets were developed
from the technology used in a Microsoft
games console but they now have
life-saving applications in the
Netherlands surgeons will be using the
AR headsets to help identify brain
tumors while in Germany AR will help
spot disease lymph nodes
in 2019 we're looking to apply augmented
reality to lots of other specialties
orthopedic surgery neurosurgery breast
reconstructive surgery penicillin was
discovered here at st. Mary's Hospital
it took 12 years from its discovery to
be used and save someone's life I'm
hoping that augmented reality and
surgery will be much quicker and once we
can demonstrate that benefit to patients
then I think it should be routinely used
[Music]
in September sports fans will turn their
eyes to Japan as it hosts the Rugby
World Cup but the tournament will be
more than just a warm-up for the 2020
Tokyo Olympics it's central to a plan to
transform the country's economy
Prime Minister avi has actually made
tourism a centerpiece of Japan's growth
strategy the government hopes to boost
the number of tourists to 40 million a
year by 2020 25 percent more than in
2017
currently around 85 percent of visitors
to Japan are from Asia but it is now
attracting more West and visitors with
far more spending power in preparation
for this boom a taxi company in Tokyo
has organized a competition to test
drivers English
thanks for dinner taxi the winner
early started learning English four
years ago and he's seen a steady rise in
foreign customers when I first became a
driver it would be twice or three times
in a week but now
once or twice a day I'm convinced - 2019
will be a great year for business
[Music]
the Japanese government also wants more
foreigners to stay in the country with
famously low immigration rates and
almost a third of citizens aged over 65
Japan is suffering from a dire labor
shortage but legislation has been passed
that will allow three hundred and
forty-five thousand foreign workers in
over the next seven years 2019 will be
the year that Japan will be undergoing a
huge change especially with what is
happening in terms of labor laws in
welcoming more migrant workers and so
this may add to you know the flavor what
it means to be Japanese in the 21st
century but with the Japanese population
shrinking by nearly four hundred
thousand a year the country may need to
welcome even more people from the rest
of the world terrible person 2019 is set
to be US president Donald Trump's most
testing yet are you that's enough put
down the mic when Democrats assume
control of the House of Representatives
and he comes under more scrutiny they
can look at us
now we can look at them I could see it
being extremely good politically because
I think I'm better at that game than
they are actually mr. Trump came to
power promising to rid Washington DC of
corruption and vested interest we are
going to drain
sois but this could be the year the
swamp really makes the president sweat
for Donald Trump I think 2019 ought to
be pretty nerve-wracking the amount of
subpoenas that are going to be arriving
at the White House and we make life
quite uncomfortable for him top of the
list for some Democrats is publishing
the president's tax returns Donald Trump
is clearly hiding something when it
comes to his finances
but it won't just be his financial
affairs under the spotlight the real
pressure on mr. Trump in 2019 could come
from the Muller investigation into
Russian interference in the 2016
election there's not really any modern
precedent for the scale you know scope
political importance of the murder
investigation they got nothing zero you
know why because there is nothing if the
investigation supports serious
allegations against the president then
2019 could be the year that the
Democrats begin impeachment proceedings
but don't expect the Republican majority
in the Senate to convict him or any
charges to even make a dent in mr.
Trump's core support across the country
if you look at president Trump's
approval ratings they don't fluctuate a
huge amount I don't see the Miller
investigation changing that you know
even if the outcome of it looks very bad
for the president all the cliches will
come out fake news thank you it's a
witch hunt
it's a disgraceful situation it's a
total witch hunt no the Democrats fault
we have Democrats that don't want to
approve anything and I think that'll be
good enough for a lot of people this is
that moment in time for our country so
for mr. Trump's political opponents the
real focus in 2019 is likely to be on
who they choose to run against him at
the next presidential election America's
politics are even more divided in 2019
than they were in 2018 in some ways that
feels appropriate divided government for
divided country
[Music]
one small step for man
[Applause]
on the 20th of July the world will
remember the moment fifty years ago when
Neil Armstrong first set foot on the
moon there were many wonderful things
that people saw in the future at that
moment
none of them was the idea that people
wouldn't go back at the fiftieth
anniversary it's going to be very clear
that people are going to go back in the
fairly near future in 2019
there will be new entrants in the race
to return to the moon Israeli nonprofit
organizations space il hopes it's Lander
will be the first lunar expedition
funded by private enterprise and other
companies like Astrobotic in the US are
also planning to get in on the action
soon the two things that have changed
since the 1960's one is that it's
cheaper to send things into space and
cheaper to send things to the moon and
the other thing is that you can do more
in space or on the moon with less it's a
sort of thing that can be done with
select private money a bit of government
involvement and a lot of enthusiasm and
that's kind of exciting not to be
outdone China's Lunar Lander should also
touchdown in 2019 making it the first
craft to land on the far side of the
Moon
but there is more than just prestige at
stake we've realized that at the polls
there are resources that it could be
quite useful for people there's frozen
water maybe frozen methane carbon
dioxide and that in turn makes the idea
of a permanent settlement on the moon
more likely and it will no longer just
be men taking giant leaps the American
astronauts who went to the moon they all
looked back on the earth with the
perspective of white American
professional men no woman has ever seen
the earth as a whole
no one of color has ever done this that
will all change in the next decade and
that will mean that the world will be
seeing itself through a wider range of
eyes and that cannot but be good
the biggest story of 2019 won't be as
some might think the UK's protracted
divorce from the European Union in 2019
a bigger broader upheaval is set to
unfold across the continent ahead of the
European parliamentary elections the
real focus next year will be the
European election when established
parties that have run Europe in one way
or another for much of the post-war era
are under unprecedented strain the
stakes are very high because people are
going to be making a statement that will
tell us a lot about whether populism has
reached its peak and is now in decline
or whether it's carrying on building
populist parties have shaken the
traditional political order across the
continent and are hoping to win more
power than ever in the 2019 vote
- the story will be about a
fragmentation of European politics and a
new divide between establishment and
anti-establishment political forces at
times in 2019 it might feel like Europe
is falling apart I find it hard to be
optimistic at this point about 2019 and
what it brings because my sense is that
the Euroskeptic cause in Europe will
continue to rise we may see the European
Parliament as should be quite quite
divided it raises the multi-billion euro
question what will all this mean for the
--use future the question isn't will
Europe survive in the short term medium
term we can be sure of that it's in what
state will it survive some of its
supporters hope that populist forces
could ultimately push the EU into
reforms which will save it and the
continents prosperity in a 21st century
Europe's going to be competing alongside
the Giants America and China so the
underlying rationale for Europe has
never been stronger and it's going to
get stronger still
[Music]
[Music]